well and and we're in the superlative
segment like we do every monday during
this season this one is the start script
uh start
writing the script award because there
will be a movie at some point disney
i've always said disney i guess i should
say universal there'll be a universal
movie at some point
about alex smith and everything he's
gone through over the past couple of
years
and i talked to him after the game and
that was my one guy
that i got to talk to him after this
game win or lose and usually we only
talk to guys from teams that have won
and he was
i almost didn't get him because he was
pissed off they lost
you know i mean he's still a competitor
this isn't my victory lap we didn't win
right that's not what he said but that
was kind of the the attitude we had to
we had to work through to get him on the
phone
he said it was and you heard that in the
clip the last six to eight weeks where
he knew
he could do it because he's back in
paths he's back and that's when it
finally became real to him that he was
going to play again and he was concerned
about taking that first hit because
think about it practice
they wear the yellow jersey in
washington you don't touch the
quarterback
no preseason this year this was his
first opportunity for contact
and he said i've spent the last two
years trying not to fall down
right right so so when he's giving aaron
donald a piggyback ride that's when he
knows
i'm good to go i mean talk about the
ultimate test of his
lower leg strength you've got this guy
on your back who is one of the great
defensive players of all time
and he's heavy and you you give him a
ride for a few steps before you go down
that made him feel like he
is back and he can get it done and now
the question is just getting into the
form that he was in a couple of years
ago
if he can do that that's the big if he's
36.
can he get back to where he was two
years ago if he can as i said earlier in
the show washington can be a force this
year yeah yeah we'll see where they get
where he gets here uh and
and we'll see where they go this week i
mean i i don't know what they'll do
it sounds like ron rivera made the
comment that if kyle allen's healthy
he'll be the starter
but i don't know uh but either way with
your like
writing the start writing the script you
can also start writing the script for
comeback player of the year
uh banquet speech too because he's going
to be that guy that's already in the
books and done
all right um hey did you see that dk
metcalf last night he's pretty good
right
who dk metcalf you heard of him that guy
that was uh you know
running all over your vikings right yeah
hey can i just say something real quick
because i know we're going to talk about
chase clay pool we talk about dk metcalf
last night on the digital thing that we
do
after the halftime uh where it's taurico
and dungeon rodney harrison and me
i i tried to get you hired by somebody
as a general manager i mean you're all
over lamar jackson in 2018
he falls to 32. you're all over dk
metcalf in 2019 he falls to
the bottom of round two you're all over
chase claypool this year he's the 11th
overall pick in the draft somebody's
gonna hire you to be a general manager
that may be my only way to get rid of
you yeah they should i was all over my
homes too so
don't forget that that's my shining one
there but i that's where i well it's
good that you're humble about it yeah
well
if
but that's exactly where i want to go i
mean you saw dk metcalf well here we go
we got dk
part two on the east coast okay and
that's chase claypool
for what he did yesterday for the
pittsburgh steelers four touchdowns
and again you just see the
person the player the specimen he is
it's very similar to dk metcalf that way
you know can catch a screen break
tackles run for a touchdown
catch a slant run away from everybody at
235 pounds
nobody can catch you you know speed
sweep tyreek hill style
get him out on the edge he can fly
touchdown that way
he is a real weapon and you know he
taught he told you some things he didn't
he didn't even know he was going to be
the focal point of the game plan but he
got it happened that way
and now i just don't know i wonder this
is going to be the jump start i would
think pittsburgh watches this film
and then goes all right it's official i
know he's a rookie but he's really damn
good we got to start making more plays
for this guy
in the weekly game plan and i talked to
him for
a solid five minutes yesterday and i've
never talked to him before he is
engaging
yeah he's he's got a little sense of
humor and and he's willing to show it on
twitter he's going to end up with a lot
of followers on twitter he had the
7-eleven tweet after the game
7-eleven always open and and i said did
you pick 11
just for that he said yeah i did i did
i've been saving that tweet and he said
no 11 different reasons like he wore 83
and
at notre dame eight plus three is eleven
this thing and family connections and
stuff but it works out well
and he was all over it and then the
shade at the goat
this one was awesome i said last night
retire the internet after this one
tom brady holding up the four fingers
with the morphing of chase claypole on
top with the four touchdowns
well done chase claypool he didn't do
that one until after i talked to him
that's a good i love that one
and and this kid this kid is just a
breath of fresh air
he um he he didn't as you said know he
was going to be
a huge part of the game plan it was when
deontay johnson got hurt he had to step
up and he steps into four touchdowns and
it would have been a fifth he had an
offensive pass interference call that
was a bad settlement
yeah he was upset about that that would
have been five now after who knows if he
would have gotten
after that that would have been four at
the time but he still could have had
another one because we saw that he did
have another one and
uh he didn't realize somebody has had
six so
he was kind of joking but kind of not
that maybe that's something he'll try to
do someday not not that
and he doesn't strike me as a guy who's
in it for his own accolades and
no i don't think so achievements because
because i said hey look you know what
it's it's they're going to be paying
attention to you now you're not going to
catch up
up anyone by surprise and he said that's
fine
if if i have a safety over the top all
the time
on top of the corner that's covering me
and somebody else can have a huge game
that's good i don't care if i have zero
catches or ten as long as we win and i
know it's cliche
but it's still refreshing to hear the
cliche instead of give me the damn ball
or
just give me a ch you know i want the
ball even if i'm double covered throw me
the ball i'll still score a touchdown
the idea that he gets it understands how
football works and if somebody else ends
up having the four touchdown game he's
fine with it he does he does get it he
does
i just you know could speak to
experience getting to know him a little
bit at notre dame
you know like you said he's got a great
way he's got charisma everything like
that
and then he's a football player i mean
on a few of those plays he had
touchdowns
and then was on the ensuing kickoff
because he had to go down there and make
tackles
and and pursuit there you know that's
what he did at notre dame and yeah he's
uh
he's got it all to be the superstar and
be that guy that
you know we talk about like dk metcalf
or other top receivers in football he
certainly does he's got the physical
ability
and to your point i think he's got the
mental awareness of
yeah he loves it but it's not all about
him he knows it's a team thing coming
from notre dame they instilled that in
him
and he does a lot of things the right
way
all right what else oh wait that was
you're up now i felt like it was mine
because i talked so much during years
all right the next one for me is
uh and look we try to be positive with
these but but uh
this one's unavoidable this is
the where is it hold on to your butts
award do you like that
this this is this goes to the san
francisco 49ers who are now two and
three
and we've alluded to this in the past
but it is upon us and more
importantly it is upon them now with all
the questions they have
about that team jimmy g should he have
played yesterday
should he have not played is he going to
play going forward is it cj beathard
where's nick mullins is he
in the doghouse permanently well they
better figure it out because next sunday
night on nbc at 8 20 p.m eastern
whoa it's the rams and then the next
week
it's the patriots whoa in new england
and then
the next week it's the seahawks in
seattle whoa
and then the next week it's the packers
should i say whoa
on sunday night oh no that's thursday
night football and then
the week after that it's the saints
right
whoa and and those five games those are
the next five games until they take
their buy
all five of them are prime time or in
the 4 25 pm eastern slot
so the world is going to be watching
what the 49ers do for the next five
weeks
and nobody associated with the 49ers
is going to want the world to see what
the 49ers do if they did more or what
they did yesterday when they lost 43-17
to the miami dolphins and then after
their buy
it's the rams and the bills and the
bills game
is monday night football six of this
seven-game
gauntlet from hell are nationally
televised games
and this team right now chris is
teetering on the brink of implosion
and i remember last year when they had
like like they had like two or three
really tough games we're like
we'll see what they are these seven
games i would wish
on no one it's brutal it really is
and you know again yesterday playing bad
you just they lose two you know two
weeks ago
to the eagles where they play poorly i
mean they just left that game out there
for philadelphia they outplayed them
they just did dumb stuff and now you
have a day where you actually show up
and
don't play well wow i mean that was a
bad loss there's no doubt about it i
don't know
what other way to say it and you know
the thing i'm worried about i just hope
they didn't sacrifice
jimmy g yesterday to where now he's not
good enough to be good this week or down
this stretch of
you know tough football games that they
got coming up because he's clearly
was not ready for action yesterday i
mean from the get-go
coach dungey and i were sitting there in
the control room like you were watching
it all
and it just from the get-go it looked
not
sharp not crips the ball never like kyle
shanahan said in the clip
you know before we started this segment
i've seen him throw the ball before
you know the last few years he doesn't
throw the ball like that yeah because he
could not
push off with that back right leg he
he could not you could see and it led to
the ball not having a lot of steam on it
a lot of wobblers we saw the ball just
float in the air
nor could he move around in the pocket
and kind of make those you know real
subtle
jimmy g oh i slide and throw a little
sidearm or whatever it is he couldn't do
any of that so
i just hope he's okay and ready to go
next week what
time out uh haven't we been over this
before subtle did i say subtle
you said you said subtotal you said
subtle i thought
yeah nothing subtle about your command
of the english language that's for sure
all right but
yeah look i i look i think i'm i pick
the 49ers to be like a
seven seed or something like that yeah
that's a stretch right now
uh yeah um look super bowl hangover a
lot of expectations the injuries
and we thought we thought they were
working their way through the injuries
well
they were playing the jets and the
giants it's all changing now and again
two and three
seven ridiculously difficult games
coming up and that may seal their fate
for 20 20. all right chris what else do
you have
joe mama ain't happy all right
you you talked to joe burrow last week
you asked him if his mom was
worried about all the hits he was taking
she said oh yeah you know he's used to
it she's seen me play a long time she
couldn't have been happy yesterday
all right because the damn bangles and
joe burrow they ran into a pissed off
ravens defense that's for sure the
ravens defense was
out you know out of this world good
yesterday whether it was creative
blitzes coverage
but the cincinnati mangoes could not do
anything and a few times had some field
position to where you go oh maybe they
can
you know it's 17 nothing it was 17
nothing for a very long time to where
you thought oh maybe they'll
you know get three get six here but no
suffocating
just all over joe burrow all day long no
no room for for mixing to run and then
of course that led to some interceptions
and some turnovers but
uh either way that ravens defense was
really good yesterday and a day where
the offense wasn't necessarily big play
or that fun to watch uh the defense kind
of won that one for them
i had that one on my list as well as the
disrespect your elders award
because lamar jackson is younger
than joe burrow and that was something
that i remember we knew last year when
lamar jackson's winning the mvp award
and joe burrow wins the heisman it was
the first time in however long if not
ever that the heisman winner was
actually ordering the nfl mvp
well that was their first encounter
yesterday burrow is indeed
older than lamar jackson so lamar
jackson did not
respect his elder and that was a that
was an
ugly game and look the bengals are going
to get their wins they just need a lot
of help around joe burrow
and it was obvious the way it played out
yesterday chris and i think that there
are a couple of drafts away and to your
point
to your point trade aj green yeah
just move on from it right move on from
it um and and look i
don't want to be overly critical of
someone's effort when an offensive
player quickly becomes a defensive
player because there are financial
reasons
for protecting yourself but if you see
the clip of aj green
after the interception first of all just
just the
it was it was loaf city to try to track
down
the defender and then at the end there
was this weird thing like he was
completely running as hard as he could
away from any and all potential contact
it was a strange little clip
and you know if the ship is sailed in
cincinnati get what you can if
mohamed sanu was worth a second round
pick last year
at the trade deadline if emanuel sanders
was worth a third round pick
i'd like to think you at least get a two
for a.j green no question get it and
move on and use that piece
to build the team that you need around
joe burrow next year yeah i think so
i mean to me you know again i don't want
to say they don't need them but they
don't need them that way they
they don't you know they got other
weapons at receiver that they can kind
of just yeah let's flourish together
joe burrow the young running back
everything all of that aj green kind of
seems out of place
with you know the old bengals the the
team that went to the playoffs five
years in a row
i still think he's got talent i don't
know if the system necessarily fits him
the way
uh you know it should either to where
it's not a great system fit they're not
getting the ball
he does have talent still he's a great
asset they should try to trade him in my
opinion so
uh i'm with you who's up here is this
you or me i'm up i'm up
this is the five for five award uh and
and this is the
the guy who's not much taller than five
feet kyla murray
he is now the fourth quarterback in nfl
history
to have five rushing touchdowns in his
first five games
and you know the one yesterday wasn't
nearly as filthy as the one from a week
or two ago where he does the double
juke that i don't think i could
replicate at any time and i don't know
you can't stand what he did with his
body i can't even explain it i can't
even begin to
even like the the these this nasty
double
double cut that he did right uh hey
look he is such a weapon and i hope they
figure out how best to harness him
how best to use him how best to counter
what the defenses are doing
they got a huge win yesterday over the
jets and it was good to see them win a
game
that they were supposed to win because
they lost a couple of games that i
thought they were supposed to win i'm
still trying to figure out where this
team is
but but they're three and two yeah
right and three and two puts them in the
mix for a wild card berth
you've got the seahawks at favano the
rams at four and one
and there are the cardinals of three and
two a game ahead of the
49ers with a tiebreaker in hand over the
49ers so
uh he joins and and let's see if you can
just let's say this isn't a full-blown
trivia question
let me see if you can guess any of the
other three quarterbacks
who's had five rushing touchdowns in
their first five games of a season
all right well i'm gonna go with mike
vick maybe yeah i'm gonna go mike no
no okay no he's gone okay what a um
wow how about one that's still currently
playing
wow it should be lamar jackson there yes
right no
no another one another one who's played
longer and had more chances to have five
touchdowns in five seasons
cam newton in his rookie year there we
go cam newton did it in his rookie year
the other two yeah are steelers
quarterbacks
all right tell me who they are
uh cordell stewart yes okay
and then wow who would that other one be
um i i really have no idea
who who would it be who quarterbacks
sneak their way to five touchdowns terry
bradshaw is that right
72. wow year of the immaculate reception
terry bradshaw five touchdowns in the
first five games i don't even think it
was the starting quarterback then which
makes it even more impressive
they had terry hanratty they had joe
gillum they had terry bradley it was a
weird
few years for the steelers before they
finally settled on the guy who was their
first overall pick in the draft uh
or a first round first overall first
round something like that they know who
we mean you got any more
yeah i do i want to give the um are you
for real
are you for real like seriously are you
guys teasing me or not
are you for real because i'm starting to
think you're for real
and i'm kind of getting excited
cleveland i'm starting to believe land
i mean the cleveland browns come on that
was awesome yesterday
i mean first off i didn't think they
could win that football game i didn't
the way the colts defense have been
playing
yeah i picked the colts i picked the
colts to be one of the best bets of the
week
saw pretty early on though that was
going to be wrong about that damn one
knew that
right away i mean cleveland just
i i mean full team win i think that's
what i'm surprised by
it really wasn't like oh they dominated
in the run game
or did they like it was a little bit of
everything
you know odell big pass jarvis you know
some big catches
baker made a few plays run game was good
enough but i think the surprise of the
day to me more than anything is the
cleveland browns defense
that has been all over the place early
this year and
they really shut down a colts offense
that's been pretty damn good
and is pretty balanced too with their
run attack and their ability to throw
the football so
i just saw that game yesterday and
like yeah i picked the colts to win
would i have been shocked cleveland
wins no but i'm shocked i guess in the
way they won it
and the fact that they really controlled
the game kind of from
get go and the colts never gotten rhythm
so from that aspect i just go
uh-oh cleveland they got something going
here and i feel like you can kind of see
it on their team and their belief and
they're just
there's a little different aura with the
browns this year than we've seen in
recent history
oh oh a lot different aura chris because
it dawned on me yesterday to take a look
at
their record from past years 2015
three wins 2016 one win
2017 no wins that adds up to a record
of 4 and 44. so from 2015
through 2017 the browns 4 and 44
this year 4-1 for a 43-game improvement
by the cleveland browns it is incredible
and their fans deserve it
and more is coming big test next week
at pittsburgh yeah but listen listen to
the rest of the schedule
for the bengals or for the browns rather
and and let's they already got four wins
in the bank
right even if they lose to pittsburgh
next week they go to cincinnati they
should win that game
the raiders come to town that's a
playoff rematch back from one of the
few years when the browns were good
brian's cited through interception in
the end zone against the
the raiders in that game 1980 i think it
was yep and it's not all that hard to
remember
brown's playoff highlights because there
haven't been that many
uh then look at this after the bye
week nine look at these games texans
win eagles win at jaguars win at titans
okay if they play that game
that's probably a loss ravens okay but
then
giants and jets back to back week 15
week 16.
i see six seven more wins
for the browns yeah i in six eleven and
five are you
kidding me i think they got a chance
but that offensive line you know the
running backs they still got
baker mayfield in the passing game i
don't even think that's really clicking
yet
and then the defense seems to be getting
more accustomed to
the scheme itself miles garrett's a
superstar
you know richardson in the middle is a
he's really awesome the guy we don't
talk about enough
sheldon richardson you know so there's a
lot of things to like about the football
team and
yeah i you know i had my doubts about
kevin stefanski he has proved me wrong
for sure here
and uh i think they got something going
they're gonna be there
you're right because the way they play
and that schedule
they've set themselves up here to almost
you
they would have to have a huge
monumental crash for us not to be
talking about them december right now
to where we they're they're in the
playoff conversation as we're going
going down the home stretch
and one last note this year's first
interim head coach romeo cornell the
oldest coach in nfl history at 73 older
than george hales when he last coat
gets the win for the houston texans over
the jaguars and a
a strange a bit of history made by the
jaguars they're the first team
to lose four straight games to winless
teams
wow uh which is just bizarre but every
they beat the cults week one every game
since then
they've lost and every team they've lost
to their first
uh win of the season here's jj watt fun
exclamation
point finally three exclamation points
is that a is that is that just relief
over the fact that they finally won a
game
is that uh something else that seems
like it's a little bit
more than just relief over the final
game does it not i don't know i i don't
know i mean
we did start the week last week talking
about a guy and the scuffle between him
and the head coach and all of that type
of stuff that went on apparently so
either way i'm sure it is fun they won i
do think that might have been a little
shot across the uh bow to billy o'brien
too
yeah and and look hey they they've
turned around whatever vibe it was that
infected the early part of their season
they got a long way to go
but the chargers did it back in 1992
starting oh and four and making it
to the playoffs and this year there's
another playoff spot for the first time
ever there's seven in the afc so who
knows what the texans will do
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports